this is the historic Cambridge Hotel in
upstate New York it's set in stunning
countryside a few hours drive from
Manhattan the hotel has 16 bedrooms and
a large restaurant and has had his doors
open for almost 150 years
welcome to the Cambridge hotel
ex-military man and local lawyer John
Inhofe persuaded his family to help him
buy the hotel in 2007 I remember sitting
in my hot tub smoking a cigar drinking
bourbon and life was good and I wanted
to take my wife someplace nice for
dinner so I said why don't we buy the
Cambridge hotel and then we'd have a
place to go he must have hit me at a
weak moment because I said sure with
zero hospitality experience between them
which one is 827 I don't I don't know
the numbers the hotel currently Falls
shockingly short of guests expectations
it's dingy and there's hair all in
through here all over these pillows be
nice if we had a remote control there's
just gobs of hair even Ed remote control
since when the 70s I'm not sleeping here
we're checking online when I bought the
hotel I didn't intend to be a hands-on
owner but I am always at the hotel doing
something one person has to be in charge
got 84 emails 17 from Jonathan job is a
control freak how we doing on that
chicken hats working hard we can do
better chef it's ready to murder with
this venue there's a lot of restrictions
to it our budgets really tight the
creativity has kind of gone out the
window but all the rooms clean all the
rooms coming in I am currently the
general manager thanks there's no but
John takes away my control I have no
control but general John's hands-on
approach isn't working
nobody wants to stay and the hotel is
losing thousands of dollars every month
John wants to put every penny that we
have into this hotel and that is
something I am no longer willing to do
we are $750,000 in debt but failure is
not an option
and I don't intend to fail hotel unless
I can fix things and fast John and Tina
will lose their business and
if Gordon Ramsay can't fix us who the
hell else can Wow
the real sense of grandeur definitely
some history here
Cambridge Hotel established 1885 home of
Pyla moat I've been across America I did
not realize it came from here morning
good morning welcome to the Gordon and
your first name sorry my name is
Brittany I'm the manager I have you in
room 117
that is $105 during the weekday and 135
dollars on the weekend okay I think
Gordon's first I'm president of the
hotel is going to be what the [__] are
these people doing the camp you tell our
IP yes sir see yes it's died you mean no
rest in peace is the ghost that huh live
here we are haunted oh come on there's a
little girl who supposedly haunts the
hotel Alice - oh my good god she looks
like something out of the Exorcist she
was four years old in 1913 when she died
but I believe in ghosts at the hotel I
absolutely believe in them can I go up
the stairs as well and oh god
I'll let the owners know I don't know
who they are they know I'm here
this place is littered with freaky
pictures what's upstairs there that is
our third floor why is that roped off
because it is not accessible to our
guests it's about yourself well that's
where people say they are if he goes up
on the third floor he is going to freak
out this is your room oh my god
bloody how look at the wallpaper
what's the post up that was was that
just there so there's no handcuffs no
okay
so there's not a sex thing really weird
thing to have in the back thank you
christ almighty I'm not gonna forget
this day in a hurry horrible linen rough
and nasty holes
and the bed doesn't even fit the base
honestly I've seen better linen inside
hospitals horrible my bedroom is dated
and uncomfortable
how could anyone think this was good
enough for paying customers bye bye
gonna meet the owners yes I'll be right
back for the owners got that they are
Gordon this is Tina and um ha
nice to meet you sir John likewise good
to see you both it's quite amazing when
you drive up and you see this sort of
statue of the building isn't it
beautiful
it's stunning until we get inside hotel
experience prior to this was was very
very little yeah that was no none none
so yeah one what was the profit we lost
about three hundred and fifty thousand
dollars the first year year to two
hundred and fifty thousand dollar profit
plus loss so we're in for six hundred
thousand dollars within 24 months of
business who's funding this well my mom
and dad have put in several hundred
thousand dollars Wow
our children our children your children
yes yes Shea has put about 25 thousand
dollars on credit cards Shea is you're
the oldest daughter you always thought
of rice the chef's significant other
okay and so my youngest daughter just
lettuce ten thousand dollars your
youngest daughter she's in college was
your house on the line next yes it is up
for sale and we would live here we would
move on to the third floor
where'd you draw the line say stop this
is not working you're standing there
like pow [__] very confident very happy
and like nothing's gone wrong but take
your money from your daughter that
hasn't even started I won't ever ask on
the path of her career I believed that
we would be able to turn it around
I know but John I'm sorry your parents
money your family's money your
daughter's money I I do have a positive
attitude there's a difference between
sounding positive and sounding full of
crap
he doesn't know me and he doesn't know
the situation I'm a military guy I'm not
gonna take Chef Ramsay's [__]
unbelievable
tear how do you manage I don't know how
I managed and I was very close to
running away several times
Wow seriously unreal
thank you I've been frustrated for years
with him not listening to me when
somebody doesn't listen to you for a
while you just give up what is that
about John that's driven his wife and
potential guests away I need to watch
the general in action
will you do with the Hoover welcome nice
to see you sorry about the owner walking
through with the Hoover are you joining
us for a sleepover or you joining us for
dinner
yeah actually Kim Jo tell me help you
John Key's himself constantly busy but
he's busy doing all the wrong things
his non stop fussing and fidgeting is
killing the hotel's atmosphere the
tables in the bar might be clean but
I've got an eerie feeling the food's
gonna be filthy only one way to find out
hello sir who are you good
my name is Philip I'll be your server
good thank you I'm a little nervous how
am I and what would recommend well the
soup du jour today is a vegetarian
lentil vegetarian lentil yep
and what was the soup as your yesterday
it was also the vegetarian I was so
super be two days actually it's longer
than two days um I'll go for the pork
and beans duck confit yeah um piler mode
okay okay I think we're done okay thank
you thank you very much chef orders up
great thank you
get them going brother get them going I
think that Gordon is gonna love the food
chef rich is great we put out excellent
food you chef
Wow look at that this is the pork and
beans
holy mackerel it
it's calling middle both you yeah just
touch that make that please oh I can see
why we got our IP on the front of the
[__] reception those are two
medium-rare is right scooter chuck them
in the oven please chef ice cold in the
middle tell them it's a sous-vide
product we cook it to order it
disappoints me a little bit that we are
boiling bags putting stuff in the
microwave I wish we could actually cook
with fresher food duck confit and chef
said the pork and beans was a sous-vide
product and it's cooked to order
sous-vide Oh put it back yes they're
frozen frozen yes and this plate that's
frozen I think that's a sous-vide
product as well do we have anything that
is homemade are the apple pies made here
the apple pies are made here okay can
you hurry the desserts please sure thank
you so far everything has been terrible
surely the hotel's signature dish is
gonna be better how's that fine
I'm sorry but this is the home of a
boiler most but if its own without
landlord it should be really badass
[Music]
Alamogordo so this is it this is the
that is the paella mode [__] this plate
is absolutely roasting the center has it
been microwaved it has the apples are
raw if there's one thing I was expecting
was a decent apple pie and that is gross
I need to find out who's responsible for
the terrible food here hello if Chef
Ramsay criticizes chef's food where is
that where is chef I think rich will
blow up because rich does take things
personally I don't know where to start
to be honest what the [__] is going on
well tell me what you don't like can you
be a little bit more constructive should
we start from the pork and beans stone
[__] cold
it's a sous-vide bravas you don't even
cook that no sue me no and can you cook
yes so why buy that in price you buy a
store-bought frozen piece of pork boiled
in a bag and serve it to me stone cold
the center
you're not even cooking so you're just
too lazy to do it that's not true I am
NOT Lisa this menu could be run now
without you being here yes that's why I
designed it this way designed it so you
are lazy then I'm not lazy if Gordon
calls me lazy or one more time
it could cause a problem might be going
back to Britain in a body bag
that menu stinks of laziness I'm not
losing I'm hearing 80 90 hours a week
yeah you can't call yourself an
executive chef come on
do you know it's store-bought I did why
would you employ a chef that's two
thirds of the menu it's store-bought I
think Gordon believes that I'm
incompetent in running a hotel but what
I'm doing is right your hotel became
famous for this apple pie right and this
is the dish that is trying to stop your
house being put up for sale to keep this
place kept I've just what I'm trying to
say is there are so many basics wrong I
could [__] cry I could seriously I
could crack it and look at the apples
look the apples are raw not even bait I
could scream when I see that and this
dish was invented here and this
thousands of restaurants across the
globe that have copied what you
originated have you no idea how luck
you are and it resolves to that soggy
undercooked
soaking wet piss pie can I have a quick
word with you for two seconds please I'm
struggling to understand what's going on
here I need to hear a woman's
perspective
John is smart in what he does as a
lawyer mm-hmm he's awful here I can't
get it in his head but between the two
of them they're about to take your
[__] house down him and John go back
and forth when I give suggestions it's
pretty much you know up and then it's
pushed aside and then John it's making
decisions you're about to lose your
house I know and he says we are going
until I haven't got another penny to put
in it is there a rule of business before
no no and he's never done anything in
his life but be a lawyer and a soldier
that is it they may have won lots of
battles but he's [__] definitely
losing this war let me tell you finally
a stranger is seeing what I've been
seeing and I'm hoping that John is gonna
take something from this and either
we're gonna make it go we're gonna shut
it up
[Music]
I've seen about as much as I can stand
at this hotel the outdated rooms the
cheap linens and the prepackaged food
how have things got this bad I've got to
get some answers what's wrong with this
place and who's to blame problem is here
is that we have to ask to do something
or not allowed to make a decision
general manager executive chef we have
to run everything arranged on make sure
everyone a [__] bath let alone oh
dear
but he's took over more control that's
when I put up my hands okay you want to
right you run it it's [__] soulless
is littered with [__] antiques that are
broken it's got horrendous pictures all
over the [__] place
disgusting ruse food that comes out of a
[__] bag and I don't control any of
that stuff I'm not making decisions I
told rich that I thought we should cut
our food cost have you got the respect
from the owners to do your job properly
yes or no no I have energy talk I
definitely do not make the decisions
that I think I should be able to though
because she's telling you that and
that's what the problem is
it's not the [__] ghost Jon they're
scaring their regulars away it's youth a
chef needs to be a [__] chef and the
general manager needs to general manage
I'm not a micromanager when we first
started this place and that the ideas I
had we're all shot shot down that's the
kind of stuff no it's coming out you've
handicapped a chef the general manager
dysfunctional and you're calling all the
[__] shots and that corner shop
you're a lethal weapon well you may
think that no I don't think that I'd
[__] know that
just heard from your wife your general
manager your chef that I'm controlling I
will control you like a little [__]
Hitler around here and if you don't stop
doing what you're doing you'll lose your
family
business I'm not a micromanager they're
not puppets they're your team and if you
don't stop doing what you're doing
you'll lose your family and the business
working out your honor I'm going to bet
good night
this is all stuff that I've been trying
to get across to John for 20 years hmm
what's the matter
seriously yeah what's the matter I've
had it I have had it now he's feeling
squashed and I don't have to feel that
way anymore I'm not gonna feel that way
anymore
bedtime boy I'm not looking forward to
sleeping in a haunted room I've never
seen such a delusional owner and staff
that are so desperate to do their jobs
and now I sleep in this christ almighty
[__] was that as bad as sound comfy
I had a sleepless night and believe me
it wasn't a ghost that kept me awake it
was something far more frightening time
to give John and Tina a wake-up call
after you please hi guys these are the
guests that have been staying in the
hotel I've asked them in my room this
morning's to help you understand how
differently has become her guests
actually stay here who'd like to go
first
I took shower this morning and used what
I thought was a clean towel and there
was hair in the talent himself was
actually very uncomfortable yeah we left
our room last night and couldn't lock
our door so we had to leave our hotel
room door unlocked handle hands how many
of you would return here anyone not much
of a nice day here John and Tina are you
aware of so many problems inside these
rooms some of them we are work yeah well
I'm more pissed off about than anything
is that last night I went downstairs in
fact let me show you it was easy if I do
this way I forgot my toothbrush I went
down to the car and I cannot believe
this just watch carefully I went outside
so step down the stairs all of a sudden
damn I've got myself out we've got no
keys to get back in the bloody front
door is not locked at night now there's
no night porter there's no security and
then shock horror I went behind the
reception desk and every one of your
keys is hanging replicated in the pigeon
box duplicate key for every room credit
card details personal cell numbers it is
all there why is the door not not
there's no good reason to go yeah we
gotta lock it in a long time no that's
two years in this community you have
eight major burglars with the last 12
months three registered sex offenders
locally in this community I mean how
does that make you feel that we were
sleeping in this hotel last night and
eating every one of us was vulnerable
thank you thank you thank you can you
stay here with me and lady in general
thank you thank you John and Tina have
broken the first law of hospitality keep
your guests safe
John so busy interfering with other
people's jobs he's lost sight of what
really matters
I'm not joking around on the burglaries
oh I'm sex a friend I know I know your
reputation to be over in seconds and one
instant in this hotel because you're not
going to walk around this town as a
prosecutor a chief lawyer and then be
responsible for a serious rape taken in
place inside here wake up you're running
a business not a courtroom and they're
here for an experience not a [__]
sentence sell the place because you're
not fit to run it sell it because this
is madness sell it and keep your house
[Music]
I've just discovered that John has lost
sight of the big picture at the hotel
the bloody front door is not locked at
night and his incompetence is putting
the guests safety in jeopardy if John
doesn't change his interfering ways he
and Tina will lose their home and be
forced to live in the hotel's top floor
it's time to find out what is like up
there
[Music]
hello anyone there hello
it's like someone Oh who in the hell put
this here
it really is hotel hell oh my god come
to our hands
this place is genuinely disturbing
freaky that top floors no place to live
but I've got a plan if I force John to
see how different things could be here
maybe he'll get the message so I'm gonna
need Britney's help if we can prove to
John and Tina if you take charge and you
hold those reins but you can make money
this hotel trust me they back off and
you step up okay I'm hoping to prove to
John that it can be busy it can be fun
here
tonight we are serving we are doing a
bar night oh my god this is terrible
we're not a rowdy kids doing shots going
crazy bar it's a party party party we're
gonna do a drink specials we can get
people in the rooms a ladies night
tonight I have to pack the place Thanks
right
this is the first step to change as
last-minute preparations take place in
the bar in the kitchen there's a new
energy in the hotel this is chef
Ritchie's chance to prove he can cook
with fresh ingredients nothing out of a
bag please no preheating all fresh sure
Alfred great rich hey sure
responsibility to teach these guys how
to cook not to reheat is that right
scoot yeah I thought he's just sorry
culinary school oh good man
how do inspired you to be a chef I heard
everywhere pushing me to join the
culinary field because I wasn't
physically able to do any other things
like sports and stuff yes disability
I've had two heart surgeries and two
back surgeries how old you know you move
fast that's a big asset
they haven't even talked properly yet
have you that's incredible so what you
want to be when you grow up I would like
to have my own bakery and I'll be a
professional executive pastry chef Wow
all right at all Brittany has gotten the
word out but she's in charge tonight and
people are flocking into the hotel
ladies night is going really well
tonight there's a mixed crowd of ages
here and everyone hanging out together
and having fun what can I do to help you
nothing get out
nice going great but I don't think John
quite understands how important nights
like this are because I don't think this
guy gets the message
John
on a show sign come with me having
spooked me every time I come in here
here's the situation downstairs
currently there's a bus and I got put
together by your general manager
Brittany that's her vision but if you
carry on running the Cambridge the way
you have been this is what you're gonna
have this is what your destiny this on
your own so stay up here and sort of
enjoy your surroundings how come we get
you when I'm ready all right
he's so wrong he has no clue and I'm I'm
thinking when he comes back up he's
gonna ask me what did I learn and I'm
gonna say don't I really didn't learn
anything pluck him
I'm not happy sitting there waiting
because I know my guests are downstairs
having a party
and I kind of felt that I needed to be
downstairs
for who wants me to sit up here and and
you know think that he's all right about
all this stuff and dammit he's wrong
about me being a control freak with
ladies night in full swing
Jesse on say I'm Jonah Tina's daughter
Shay arrived adjoining the phone I think
she's my last chance of getting through
to join I say thank you time's running
out for you dad for your mother and for
their house I can't get through to your
father I asked him to go upstairs and
just sit and ponder and think that this
is your future if you think he's ready
to change by all means bring him down
and if he's not I don't care keep him
out there and keep him up there what's
going on I'm just up here sitting down
waiting waiting go back go surf I think
the point was to try and visualize what
could potentially be the future oh no
I've been doing a lot of thinking hey I
thought my role was about the same all
along I feel like it's changed a lot and
I think a lot of it is a fear of
trusting
you don't have to be here all the time
and when was the last time you sat down
at home and how to dinner with mom you
know yeah I feel guilty when I'm not
here
do you know what's going on downstairs
no it's awesome there is a restaurant
full of people that are thoroughly
enjoying themselves
it's happen and it's working without you
yeah yeah I'm getting it okay I mean I'm
it's gonna be tough for me to backwalk
of the working I think it's important
for you I think it's important for you
and Mom yeah you're making a good point
Shay I think you would be able to spend
more time with your granddaughter sorry
I bet it's possible you don't want this
to be your future no you don't want to
live here no I don't you have to commit
to change yeah yeah all right I
understand if mom will put up with me
being home more love you I love you too
shape
I've an epiphany I've just now realized
my control is what Dre is dragging the
hotel down now I need to make a change
in order for my personal life to improve
and for my business to get better
tonight has been a real success seeing
Brittany in charge and rich cooking
fresh food gives me real hope but it's
Jon capable of letting go my goodness it
feels weird it's sounding so quiet now
right
well done behind the bar well done in
the kitchen
scooter well done ladies great I mean
you couldn't get a seat at the bar
within 20 minutes that's how it should
be how much do we take center $1400 in
two hours $1400 in two hours we made
more than the last four Wednesday's are
for Thursday's combined Jon you spend
the majority night upstairs how was your
night it was in a very good night
actually no way
my daughter Shea opened my eyes to some
things I'm here every night because I
feel that I need to be here that that is
my role as the owner to wave the flag as
a military term but when it came from
Shea as she said you know dad mm-hmm I
know how hard you work and and I
promised I wasn't gonna tear up and this
all happened without me you trust your
subordinates as a commander the most
important person you have are your NCOs
and chef and Brittany are my NCOs I
can't tell you how good is to hear that
because you're a [__] tough nut to
crack
because we have got one hell of a day
tomorrow but I need everybody everybody
at their best a good job well done
what are they
I'm hoping that John has finally got
that message but it's all lawyer crap
tomorrow we'll definitely find out
my design team worked all night to bring
the hotel into the 21st century now it's
time to reveal then you came with your
tell to the staff good morning good
morning John how you feeling I can't
wait to see what you've done in there
right you ready to go in the only way
we're getting in is with this okay let's
go let's go
the door is locked so your guests can
sleep safe and sound right come upstairs
I'm hoping you're gonna love my room I
think it's absolutely gorgeous
[Music]
taking the carpet out and putting that
flooring in absolutely transformed it
the whole paper was expensive in order
to enhance a we work with it so we got
the back drapes above the vet we have
this amazing new floor perfect furniture
that fits the room we've got graded
every room with brand-new linen and
towels $75,000 worth of linen oh my god
oh my god
we could have never afforded that that
is so wonderful I feel like kind of like
a kid that comes down Christmas morning
and there's so many things under the
tree that you're in overload I can't
really comprehend everything yet I mean
I'm just kind of looking at it ring Wow
ready for more room oh my god I could
take it Wow Wow I can't wait to actually
show a guest upstairs to a room I'm
there's one more little thing I want to
show you downstairs come with me please
in the 1890s that came is your tale gave
birth to world-famous Pilar mode and I
think that dish can put the hotel back
on the map today something I thought was
a huge missed opportunity I've been
working on an amazing very special apple
pie recipe that I'm gonna give to you
that you own then it becomes the best
apple pie in America and on the back of
that we've transformed this room through
here
- the alamode room completely yeah
morning everybody how are we we can sell
our own pie that's homemade that Gordon
is giving us his recipe for oh my god
this Hotel invented pie limos and the
ice cream is made fresh here with a
brand new ice cream maker and it's
locally sourced cream I can't wait to
try it
come with me please I enjoy the apple
pie nice to see you
please come through beauty-full pile of
most to get dig in call guys if anybody
wants this you better get on it oh my
gosh awesome the world-famous Cambridge
hotel apple pie a la mode that is the
best crust I have ever had on a pike
welcome to the Cambridge Hotel we now
have the best apple pie lamode in let's
say the world people gonna be excited
what do you think but I'm shocked you're
short
be happy I don't know oh my don't get
upset buddy what's the matter I'm so
happy oh good I'm happy too as well you
know that okay
Thank You Lee seeing how much he James
hotel is very overwhelming
I can feel a chance I'm a lot more
inspired right now I feel like I could
accomplish anything in the kitchen
I am proud now there's a new pride in me
to say this is where I work
time to go I never thought I'd say this
but I'm actually quite sad to leave this
place because no longer is John in
denial he can now stand back and watch
his team run the Cambridge properly as
I'm getting ready to leave
yes I starting to arrive at the new
hotel hello and the biggest change of
all is not the new decor it's the fact
that guests are loving it at the
Cambridge beautiful the restaurant is
buzzing guests are enjoying the new
home-cooked menu that have put together
with chef rich and you better save room
for the pie cuz it's totally different
and the hotel's signature dish pie
lamode is a big hit great buzz in there
I mean it's electric and it's the sound
of the new Cambridge otels only hope now
is that they keep it up and keep those
customers excited because when it's like
that
it's phenomenal I think tonight went
incredibly well that the fact that I
could stay and sit with Shea and Addison
and funk it was really really nice Wow
to see you smiling he's incredible you
know that's you like this place up but I
don't what you're living here no one I
don't want to live here I do not want
you living here don't live here okay
tell him that I'm not living here I hear
you give him a hug he deserves
he hasn't interfered tonight and you sat
down and spent time with your
granddaughter
I had a blast yeah my job is done let me
tell you no longer our IP okay of the
Cambridge it has a bright future long
live the Cambridge right gamma died
before Gordon came I didn't know where
to go anymore with the hotel and getting
Gordon here and having him show us what
the problem was now I can see that the
things can be fixed I tell you okay
Colin Powell says
optimism is a force multiplier I'm
optimistic stay optimistic but don't get
too volved okay okay look after
yourselves thank you very much stay
together thank you thank you thank you
before I leave this place there's one
more person I want to talk to qualit big
man so you got three more years left at
college right I'm out for okay hear me
out okay I want you to keep in touch
with me okay I leave my email address
because I want to finance those next
four years in college personally and
help you okay do it for you and keep
that dream alive
one day of owning your bakery and then
when your bakery is open all I want back
is a loaf of bread okay it's pretty
unbelievable that he is gonna be able to
finance my four years of school well
done good job they can get the watch
welcome yeah I'm waiting to finish
school and pay em off for their big loaf
of bread you have an amazing pair of
hands and a lovely smile don't stop
okay and God help you if you fail that
college thank you you won't though I
know you won't
welcome thank you okay when I go to
school I'm gonna push myself two hundred
times harder I'm gonna sugar in what I
can do and how fast I can do it good
night thank you thank you take care
thank you well done thank you good job
awesome job hey you deserve it
definitely what a week
what a place now whatever I see Ella
mode I know where he started